thank you for joining us America we're
so glad you are with us in Canton Ohio
pastor Stan is on the line hey Pastor
Stan how are you hey Dave I'm doing well
how are you today better than I deserve
sir so I understand your entire church
you have paid off the church we have we
we have been working hard in in December
here just this past December we we paid
off our entire mortgage 7.3 million
dollars since we moved here in 2001
since 2001 and so that makes us a 15
year plan okay very cool and what's the
name of the church the church is first
Friends Church here in Canton Ohio
and how many in attendance on average
are in membership or however you count
it yeah right now we've got about 1100
on a Sunday morning okay very cool very
cool now I have you done a push lately
or is this printing pretty steady over
this 15 years tell me about the journey
well we we have been steady but in 2007
we really took a larger step more of a
debt snowball kind of step we had one of
our elders doing home and who kind of
had an inspiration while he was mowing
the lawn to start something called a
freedom campaign which really in 2007 we
really got aggressive with with paying
down the paying down the principal and
actually since 2007 the creation of the
freedom campaign we've really
sacrificially paid off 2.6 extra million
dollars in principle we really have so
in the last seven years on two of them
two and a half million a bit way to go
very cool yeah that's great that's great
so is the congregation on an individual
basis are they learning about on their
personal level getting out of debt - yes
as a matter of fact there's been a long
history of great biblical stewardship
being taught here than Church were seven
years old actually this year but the
last
the last seven or eight to ten years
we've had a real emphasis with Dave
Williams leading our Financial Peace
University classes and we've got a whole
new generation since the Larry Burkett
and Crown Ministry days got a whole new
generation of folks really looking at
how the Bible says to handle finances
and it's made a huge DNA difference in
our church yeah once the the people at
home get their home life straightened
out there giving changes and it changes
the church as well then that's very neat
very cool very cool and a great history
there too it sounds like that that's
amazing very very well done pastor will
congratulations how does it feel to be
running a debt-free operation
pardon me how does it feel to be running
a debt-free operation well already you
know we're talking about what we built a
first phase here and so you know what
are the next phases what's God calling
us to what what generosity projects we
want to continue to grow in our in our
giving in the community and around the
world so all of those things we feel
that we're so excited to be able to look
with with new eyes at those
opportunities yeah well you've got some
margin now I mean you got the ability
both stinking debt payments going out
you can help a whole lot more people
that's awesome whether it's in the
community or whether it's mission work
around the world you've got some get
some green back to do it with that's
very cool
I'm very proud of you guys
congratulations and thanks for calling
in to share that a church when it's
intentional can become debt-free as well
so very cool so I understand the whole
congregation stood up and did a
debt-free scream together is that right
we did on January 31 we had a big debt
free service and had a big celebration
shredded the mortgage and we filmed a
big debt-free screen for you all right
well here we go seven point three
million dollars paid off in 15 years two
point six of it in just the last seven
years count it down first Church and
what's the first Friends Church I'm some
here in Canton Ohio count it down let's
hear a debt free scream Church three two
one
that's a very sick piece of video people
celebrating everywhere that's awesome
very very well done I love it I love it
I love it excellent job hey you guys
Rachael Cruz here hope you are enjoying
the Dave Ramsey show and did you know
that I have my very own YouTube channel
yes that's right it's kind of better
than the Dave Ramsey channel I'll tell
them I said that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you